est ce que vous voulez oui ou non chasse
touicha pourquoi mon petit bijou elle
revient alors à l'optimisme par contre
si tu mets une musique tous faim qui
s'est alors un piège japonais g après ça
pour être devant une vitrine de
pâtisserie à tous elle va écouter et
mais ça a fait du rugby un way beaucoup
de rugby vous aimiez vous jouez à quel
poste moi jouer arrière et ce en
seulement assez sympa c'est un poste que
je kiffe parce qu'on peut s'intercaler
comme on veut dans la ligne d'attaqué
assez intéressant je sais moi j'adore ma
fait recaler aussi on m'appelle
l'intercalaire dans les milieux du sexe
moi je pense que mathieu peux pas me
livrer à je veux dire pourquoi vous avez
un peu la coupe de kenji vrai qu'elle
avait du succès la coupe à la botte sa
joie tous les footeux tous les mecs un
peu beau gosse si l'on la coupe bien
rasé comme ça héros comme ça a c'est du
boulot mais ses chances à dire pas plus
de quinze jours tu c'est vrai bâton que
tu repasses au salon aymeric est avec
et louis bonnery sait il le sait c'est
quelqu'un que je suis depuis plusieurs
années et il sait que je m'assoie
démarrer mais je crois beaucoup pour lui
vraiment méricourt eric maskin à une île
et il a quelque chose et je suis heureux
d'être là je vous kiffe et baptisé tetra